change starts at home
i i you know saying that the politicians
have to change
like everybody knows that but they're
not going to because they have become
more finite minded which is an election
is a finite game there's a beginner
there's a beginning middle and end and
there's a winner and there's a loser but
the minute you win your election now
governance is an infinite game but the
problem is they don't make that
conversion and and it used to be it used
to be and i talked to um some
congressmen about this some old timers
and they were explaining to me that back
in the day 80 of the negotiations would
be done behind closed doors and the last
20 was for the cameras
and now it's 100 for the cameras
and
uh in the back in the day
the goal was that
each party could go back to their
constituents and say we won and they
could go both go back and say we got
what we wanted and appease their
constituents now it's not enough to say
we won we also have to demonstrate the
other side lost which is a finite
mindset in an infinite game which
decreases
trust cooperation
and um
uh
and but if if we want to go backwards
and look to the root i think that
contract for america
back in the day
uh one of the one of the components of
that and but this is not political i i
don't care about the politics of it but
there was a component of it that said to
congressman
no longer don't move your family to
washington when you get elected
stay home in your constituency so now
what happens is you have congressmen
come to work for about three days in
washington and then fly home and they're
not meeting their constituents they're
fundraising for for five days a week
right but the problem is back in the day
they fought
and they disagreed and they hated each
other but
they sat in the bleachers together to
watch their kids play baseball and they
went to the same pta meetings and they
were friends and they socialized and
it's really easy to compromise with a
friend and you could sit back and be
like i can't do that you know i can't do
that you know but now there's no
friendships they don't know each other
they sleep on their couches at work and
they only know the people they hang out
with which is their own party we don't
want to go into gerrymandering as well
you know we used to live in a world
where you know we picked our electors
now our electors pick us
um and so they don't work they don't
have blended um uh districts anymore
where they have to have a point of view
that appeals to both sides they've
they've both sides have gerrymandered
the point they only have to appeal to
your own so they've both gotten
more extremists
but to answer your question directly
without you know i'm sorry i had to go
on the little diatribe but the to answer
your question more directly i think our
politicians are a reflection of us
i think we get what we deserve
and
this is none of this is a surprise and
none of this is an anomaly it's all been
a steady drum beat if we just go back
40 years you can see the steady drum
beat to republican and democrat
the steady drumpy towards more and more
finite and it's just come to a head
these days it's been getting worse for
decades
uh since basically the fall of the
berlin wall you can go back to about
um where that where it started and and
and we are the ones who are complaining
they need to compromise they need to
listen they need to work across the
aisle they need to stop being less
judgmental well hello
we need to compromise we need to listen
we need to work across the aisle we need
to be less judgmental it's us
and i think change always starts at home